uh si oh if I if I was to give it a name
I would call it uh hey I just met you
and this is crazy but you're dead I'm
gonna move on maybe that's the formula
of Si oh hey I just met you this is
crazy you're dead I'm gonna have a baby
like that's the whole show ya know that
like no joke that's the show that's
really that's all of SEO with some
swords which may be [ __ ] swords it's
not a bad anime but I wouldn't call it
the best or and I wouldn't even call it
great I would call it like mediocre if
anything I'll call it like just yeah
just good just above yeah it's just good
I just just above something like it's
something like say something totally
mediocre is like a typical Shonen like
say Naruto or it's just above that you
know yeah it's above I would say it's a
lot like our Exorcist in a lot of ways
just more memorable well I liked ain't
no Exorcist oh I don't know out Isis
just ended on filler from episodes like
17 or both [ __ ] you heard it here first
verbose [ __ ] okay well guess I'll get on
to what I've been watching finally yeah
well I've been watching recently is a
show called my little sister can't be
this cute Oh
Sugoi we haven't watched that show yet I
have to ask you garen Oh God okay what
do you think of it oh my god like I know
what you're gonna say because I thought
the same thing you feel bad don't you
yeah I feel you shouldn't be liking it I
the only reason why I really watched
Oreimo was because someone requested it
to me and I was going to review it for
them but then I'm watching it and I
didn't feel like it was amazing
and I didn't feel like he was horrible I
just kind of felt like it was normal and
I didn't get the all the hype about our
mori emo and like almost it's [ __ ]
looking awesome
like I think
can we just make that a catchphrase of
this podcast it's [ __ ]
see another thing is is I are not online
is [ __ ]
my name's sister caught me this cute
it's [ __ ] exhale whatever so there's a
point legend of the Galactic Heroes it's
wait it's actually pretty [ __ ] good I
don't know I'll be back in a minute
another it's either it's [ __ ] or it's
it's the [ __ ]
it's tradition now and this episode is
called how to ruin your reviewer
credibility in 15 minutes
we like harems Elmo peanuts and hen
night hentai of entire games a little
sister's a moto so have you watched
anything else since we're destroying a
credibility right um I haven't seen
monster that's that's 72 episodes that's
also understandable it's monster good
though
Oh monster it is really good yeah thing
yeah it's [ __ ] awesome it's [ __ ] you
know you know now missus this podcast is
gonna be saying that uh everything that
that I think I think we decided on the
title for this pod pod carpet suc
website for it [ __ ] [ __ ] and that is
part aku see you next time boy and done
hey guys guys guess what I thought about
that ending what is [ __ ]